you know I'm genuinely annoyed at the
revelation that I don't own a spider-man
t-shirt I gotta fix that so spider-man
far from home I have seen it I actually
got to see it with my partner Liz she's
not joining me for the review because we
saw it at a late night and she didn't
feel like doing the review right away
and then she had stuff she had to do so
it's just gonna be me but we had fairly
similar thoughts on the thing overall so
let's do the simple question first is it
better than spider-man homecoming no is
it as good as spider-man homecoming no
is it bad no so this and I will also
point out that it seems to be getting
reviews fairly consistent with what the
previous film got so this might be a
case where the things that don't work
for me are unique to me maybe I'm the
weird one here but this talking about
this film also puts me in a bit of an
awkward situation because most of the
stuff that I like I can't talk about
until I start talking spoilers which
puts me in a difficult position because
it basically means keeping it keeping
the front end of this spoiler free means
I'm only gonna get to talk about the
things that didn't work so well so I am
gonna kind of talk in broad strokes for
a bit broadly speaking my the simplest
way to sum up my issues with this is
that I found the first hour to not be
exceptionally entertaining I'm not gonna
say that it's not good but what it's
doing is not what I wanted now at about
the halfway
about an hour in it kicks into high gear
and heads into what I wanted and I
actually really like the second the back
half of this film quite a bit that front
half though it's still yeah yeah okay
the previous film homecoming I thought
was incredibly well-balanced in terms of
how it juggled the school social stuff
and the superhero stuff not just in
terms of how much we got of each but
when it went from one to the other and
how it flowed from one to the other
because I know some people really like
the soap opera that spider-man can be
that's not like I appreciate that that
helps give spider-man his unique flavor
but that's not what I'm here for
that's never what I'm here for so for me
when it's done well which I feel it was
in homecoming it's like it's like good
seasoning it's it's it's just the right
bit of spice to what I am there for to
make it a little different a little nice
but after a cold open the first twenty
minutes of this film is uninterrupted
social school non heroics stuff and for
me that's like giving me a you know
going to a dinner and my first course is
just a bowl of salt and pepper
I needed this sprinkled over everything
else don't just give that to me straight
it doesn't work straight for me at least
and I think a lot of this just has to do
with my own genre preferences because
that I'm in a lot of the first hour but
that first 20 minutes especially is
really just a fairly typical high school
teenage social comedy basically and I
really like those kinds of movies that's
not the kind of movie I would choose to
go to it's it's just it's not my bag so
having and again I couldn't swallow it
better in homecoming because it I did I
wasn't getting it uncut it was like a
little bit here a little bit
there here's here's a slightly awkward
moment with with Liz here's an awkward
moment with Ned but it wasn't like
awkward moment awkward moment or awkward
moment our hormone like I know Peters
awkward and that's part of what makes
him charming but don't stack them up
like that on me and also I feel like
with some of these characters they have
upped the cringe factor or they have
upped what made them kind of funny the
first time to the point that it now
makes me cringe a bit and I've talked
about my dislike of cringe humor now
this happens actually with several
characters but the one that best
exemplifies it there's a there's a
teacher character and he was in the
previous one he was he's the teacher
with the beard and he was you know
guiding the the kids in Washington DC
and you know he's a bit of a dopey you
know teacher he's not cool he's a little
awkward and that's fine the amount of we
got of that before was just fine but now
we get a lot more of it and it's all
consistent it's not like he's suddenly
like a different character but it's like
oh god they really laying it on thick
this time oh okay and I like I got tired
I thought he was funny last time I got
tired of him real fast and that happened
in a few other places there's also a new
character introduced who seems to exist
simply to be a potential romantic rival
for MJ but he doesn't need to be because
Peter has an ax has enough rivalry or
insecurity within the school characters
that we know we didn't need this guy he
doesn't add anything and that
performances wouldn't as heck I don't
know why he's there
I really don't like him Brad Jones I
think is the character I didn't like him
at all I don't know why he's there but
okay III again I can talk about this
without getting the spoilers the
performances are good Tom Hollands very
good he's very lovable he's very
enjoyable I actually quite like this
interpretation of Aunt May she is
decidedly different from what we
normally get from Aunt May but I like it
like
the changes that have been made to these
characters they never feel arbitrary
they feel informed for the vibe that
this these films want to have and she
feels consistent with that we get happy
Hogan in this one which is also nice
because Jon Favreau is good in that part
it's kind of effortless for him at this
point
MVP though I gotta be honest for this
whole film is India as MJ I liked her in
the first movie I really loved her and
this she is awesome and I think it's
such a terrific take on MJ because if
you're going to attempt to update
spider-man and please keep my update
does not mean do it better it just means
bring it in line with current times if
you're gonna update spider-man which
this does it's what the whole thing is
that because like the token McGuire
spider-man it was very much while it was
set modern day was very much
deliberately designed to evoke the 60s
and 70s of spider-man so it was sort of
deliberately anachronistic in a lot of
ways especially with the some of the
character dynamics with these films that
are connected to the MCU they are trying
to be of this time and to feel of this
time not just be ostensibly set here and
so if you're gonna take a character like
MJ who in the comics and in the Raimi
movies was you know just the the
bombshell she's pretty and everyone
thinks she's awesome and trying to
update give us a slightly more modern
take on that well you know the pretty
girls don't always automatically make
them the cool ones sometimes the cool
people are a little bit odd a little bit
aloof a little bit in her case a little
bit morbid but what I really love about
her performance here is as she opens up
to Peter a little bit we see that that
front that very cool chill front that
was pretty much all we got of her in the
previous film is layered over very
typical teenage insecurities that she
also sells really well and it doesn't
feel like a betrayal of the character it
feels like we're getting to know you
better
just like Peter is oh that's nice
this is fun plus you have one line that
I am
immediately turn to listen and what
you're gonna steal that aren't you and
it's been in some of the trailers so
I'll say it because Peters sister you
look pretty and she just turns to him
and merely goes and therefore I have
value oh I really did love that as far
as other characters go Nick Fury and
Maria hill are in this they are they are
entertaining they're a little odd
they're using this is a little odd but I
can't get into that without getting into
spoilers so I won't
we have Jake Gyllenhaal as Mysterio and
he plays the part well I as with a lot
of the film though I think his best
stuff is in the second half both in
performance and as a character the
action is good the visuals are great
like it's a good film it's just like it
took a while to kick into gear for me
and now I am gonna start to give in
spoilers because I do want to talk more
about the stuff that I really liked
because you know I've done my
complaining about the front end and my
prey Z is in the back end so ah or I say
praising I am gonna initially start with
another complaint but it is spoilery so
part of the thing that was tough for me
is that I know who Mysterio is now
Mysterio isn't isn't like super unknown
I mean like if you know spider-man and
all you know Mysterio but he's not like
you know he's not iconic he's got a
pretty distinct look but he's not like
Oh everybody knows him he's not he's not
an equivalent of like the Joker of the
Riddler like oh yeah I know we've heard
of him I said wait who so I don't know
how genuinely they were trying to have
it be a twist that he's the spoilers
that he's the villain but the fact that
and and the fan I'm not sure they are
because after the movie's over I asked
Liz like how quickly did you Corden on
that he was gonna be a problem she was
like Oh almost immediately I'm like did
you know about that character head time
she's like no but I just figured so I
don't think they're actually trying to
play it as
twist which makes it all the weirder to
me that they kind of let him appear to
be a good guy for an hour an hour of
runtime almost like that's that's too
long to be to be playing that shell game
when I definitely anyone who knows the
character at all and anyone who's like
paying any attention even if they don't
know the character can probably figure
out that there's something weird going
on with this guy and so I think they
wait too long to let the oshu drop on
that once they do we get some really
good stuff there is an action sequence
in the middle of this film that is like
the first real it's the first proper use
of Mysterio's holographic illusions in
combat when he's fighting spider-man
it's so cool the way he messes with
spider-man's sense of where things are
where he is what's going on around him
I'm not gonna talk any of the specifics
about this actions he wants but I love
it so much the way that he he keeps him
on the back foot and disoriented and
it's all happening so fast that you
totally buy that even though Peter knows
God this all has to be fake it's still
happening to him so fast yesterday acts
so quickly that something's happening is
like I have to assume that that might be
real cause if it if I'm wrong this goes
really bad and Mysterio is using that
against him it's really really good like
especially compared to how we've usually
seen Masseria depicted like when he
showed up in cartoons or what he just
you know creates this like this one
illusion this this sequence mysterious
like creating this free-flowing
environment where like this becomes this
like it's like a funhouse dream logic on
speed it's awesome and the later combat
scenes aren't quite at the same level
it's not one in the middle but they're
also good I like that mysterious
I like that Mysterio has an entire team
of people made up of folks who felt
screwed over by Tony Stark cuz
let's be honest as much as Tony was a
hero Tony also left a long legacy of
being a jerk and we had that a bit with
the vulture before and now we get it a
bit more but it does feel distinct
enough from the vulture because with the
vulture that was when Tony screwed over
the little guy and probably
inadvertently probably not meaning to
whereas a lot of these folks were like
actually in Tony's employ and we're
screwed over more directly than Adrian
Veidt aka the vulture was so that's kind
of cool I like that we get a few like
very specific who this person was and
you know with reference to earlier films
that's kind of a neat touch I like that
I mentioned fury and Maria Hill being a
little off they feel off in terms of the
performance they're fun they're engaging
they're kind of funny they feel a little
off which basically gets reckoned in the
in the post-credits sequence because we
find out at the end
that's not Maria Hill and Nick Fury
that's a couple of that's Telos and I
forget the other scroll the other
Scrolls name but that's a couple of
Scrolls pretending to be Nick Fury Maria
Hill Nick Fury's off world right now and
that is that was an interesting twist I
don't think they should ever try and
pull this trick again but that was kind
of a neat way to have their cake and eat
it too because they for the sake of this
story and I think they did cut because
Nick Fury has to fall for Mysterio's
stick he otherwise the story doesn't
work properly and he also still kind of
does have to be there because somebody
needs to be pressuring Peter to be in
the places where he's going to be for
things to go and Nick Fury basically
recruiting him because other Avengers
are busy that serves that function so he
has a narrative reason to be there and
also the narrative Canada demands that
he not be as on his game as he usually
is
so they
to have Nick Fury fill his narrative
function even though it felt slightly
out of character and then justified in
the end credits sequence like I said
haven't your cake you needed to it's
actually really clever
I was I was quite impressed with that um
try to think what else I think
um the initiative was kind of thrown off
by the whole thing with Edith initially
sort of thinking like would Tony
actually have trusted Peter was
something like something that big that
dangerous but then I stopped a lot about
yeah yeah he might cuz I think he kind
of saw Peter as potentially the next him
and in his mind he could handle all that
Peter will be fine you know not having a
full appreciation of how young Peter is
we got a couple different suits in this
we get the black cell suit we've got the
night monkey suit which is fine it works
and then we get the the red and black
which I I really do enjoy that Peter got
to work the materials and designing
himself and we take that pause we're
happy sees him you know with the
Holograms piecing the suit together and
he never says you know you look like
Tony but we can just see what Peter's
doing and if we didn't make the
connection alright we see the look on
happy Hogan's face and be like oh yeah
so there's some nice nods to to Tony and
Iron Man and which it kind of needed
given how important he was in the
previous film in this specific city of
what I said previous how I mean
homecoming not like previously release
though he was important and that too cuz
that was then give me anyway you know
what I mean why am i over clarifying so
like really once this thing had hit the
halfway mark it really took off and who
really clicked for me pretty much from
far the entire remainder of the runtime
but that first hour I checked my watch
twice I don't check my watch during
Marvel movies as a rule of thumb I don't
check my watch during most
so if I'm checking my watch at all
that's a problem if I'm checking my
watch twice in just a half length of the
movie that's a big problem or at least
is an indicator that something's really
not working for me and I don't want to
be like I'm checking about what's going
God when is this over I was checking out
what's going how long have we been doing
so like when I said 20 minutes an hour
I'm not guessing I know that's how long
it was that it was 20 continuous minutes
of high school cringe humor and that it
was an hour until it kicked into a gear
that made me go yeah because I was
checking my watch so once it got good it
got real good and and thank goodness too
because it reminded me of all the things
that I loved about the previous film and
also absolutely stay for the end credits
well why am I saying this then the
complete spoiler section so I'll just
talk about the other and credit thing
the way that they ended I'm actually
gonna be really curious how this goes so
we get Jay jonah Jameson back basically
it's the version of Jay jonah Jameson
from the ps4 video game he is an online
puppy he's basically Alex Jones
basically but they got JK Simmons back
which they kind of had to cuz no one
else can be Jay jonah Jameson it just
won't work
um but I do like that you know he's bald
and like he's not the literal same guy
he looks different enough and his
presentation is completely different in
terms of how he's delivering his
information in this message so it makes
it very clear that this is a distinctly
different version of Jay jonah Jameson
then we got when JK Simmons did it so
perfectly in the Raimi films now the
ending is the ending of the first of
this is the mid credit thing is kind of
interesting in that it mirrors what
happened at the end of homecoming when
on may you know saw that Peter was my
era man you know what up and then doing
it now with Jay jonah Jameson dropping
that Peter is spider-man
on the world has set up by Mysterio cuz
yeah which was also a nice thing like
this this was actually major seven
surprise they held some of this for Meg
credit but I like I was wondering cuz he
was like no we're gonna move forward
even after the illusion of the elemental
broke down that was a cool way to like
sort of offhandedly have villains like
hydro-man and molten man just adding
that in there said Ben you know his his
composure it was like I don't know how
you're gonna spend this I wondered that
too and now we know I do worry a little
bit about what the next film picking up
is gonna be like now though because if
they follow through with this
and Peter's cover's blown that worries
me because spider-man is the only
character Marvel's doing the secret
identity with and it's not that I like
love the secret identity but that's the
one well that they have to tap that sort
of thing in most of the other characters
definitely the ones that are leading
their own franchises are kind of known
to the public who they are and I worry
about them removing one of the things
that is unique to this character within
the Cinematic Universe but we won't know
until it picks up next time it actually
honestly turned out that on may finding
out what ended up not being a very big
deal so maybe this will be a similar
thing I don't know we'll see but once it
got good it got very good took a little
while to get there though spider-man far
from home you've seen it what do you
think about it whatever your thoughts
are drops let me down the comments let's
talk about it there's a bunch of stuff
to do down there too cuz there's the
page on where you can support me really
appreciate it
um there's also you know subscribe and
the like button that's a big help and
you know all sorts of links down there
for my socials in my book and my p o--
box etcetera etc etc check them out or
don't I like I really appreciate it but
I'm not gonna tell you what you have to
do because at the end of the day folks
you're the council
I'm just running meetings and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]